serán elegidos gobernadores de 28 de los
36 estados que componen el país más
poblado de África en Nigeria estos
comicios podrían ser delicados para el
partido gobernante El Congreso de todos
los progresistas del nuevo presidente
bola chinobu cuya elección del mes
pasado está impugnada por la oposición
es en Lagos uno de los 10 estados con
mayor producto interno bruto de África
donde los resultados podrían ser más
apretados He venido a votar he salido a
las siete de la mañana he salido por un
nuevo lagos por primera vez en dos
décadas la mega ciudad de 20 millones de
habitantes podría escapar de la
influencia de bola el actual gobernador
de lagos babaji deu es considerado por
muchos como El títere de
chinobur del partido laborista un
arquitecto de 40 años podría sucederle
promete una ruptura con la anterior y
más transparencia e inversión y
Transporte salud y educación
es muy lamentable que el estado de lagos
haya estado gobernado por personas que
sólo se dedican a la intimidación y a la
violencia y por la gracia de Dios al
final del día de hoy su reinado y su
práctica de la violencia y de la
intimidación en el estado de lagos
terminará se prevén otras elecciones
reñidas en los estados de rivers en el
sur y Cano en el norte del país
estos comicios se celebran en un
contexto en el que la oposición denuncia
los fallos de la comisión electoral
independiente y en el que las elecciones
presidenciales del 25 de febrero
estuvieron marcadas por deficiencias
técnicas y retrasos en la transmisión
electrónica de los resultados lo que
provocó la ira de una parte del
electorado